ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita ha buttata stiamo forse
parlando della puntata più attesa di
sempre qualcuno di voi avrà capito sto
parlando di regali di questa puntata è
stata sponsorizzata da now tv che tra
parentesi ringrazio perché sono proprio
realtà come queste che mi permettono
anche di trasformare vita buttata in un
qualcosa di sostenibile io non so chi vi
parla è un pacco con questa stigma è
stata regalata da motivi che penso si
sia fatta impietosire tra i regali
orribili che ho ricevuto l'anno scorso
per la maggior parte dei miei parenti
quindi grazie mille tantissimi hanno
pure dato un'idea su cosa regalare
quest'anno un po di amici malati di
serie tv che conosco tra cui matteo
bruno che siete la regala posso
chiederti di apprezzare questa
decorazione natalizia che abbiamo fatto
proprio per l'occasione è bellissima in
camera e bellissima bellissima mai
quello che propongo io adesso è di
smettere per le libere ghali e di
tuffarci ai regali ritto a capofitto nel
pozzo nero del cattivo gusto legali
bellissimi ma perché vedevo farlo
davvero natale si sa lui va bene a me fa
molto ridere di questo cappello che la
faccia poi è compressa in un piccolo
cerchio che dire passiamo subito
[Risate]
problema di mare che ogni natale e
melegati collegava per un popolo col
pigiama uguali
accappatoio questa volta che si assumerà
da quanto ricorda il problema regalati a
permettergli di tutto il video dello e
ci ha regalato il telecomando universale
per la televisione della camera c'è una
sottotrama che non siamo considerati lui
intanto sta svaligiando un appartamento
sangue nel palazzo chigi è stato
abbassato ma le vuoi io ho provato a
quello più bello ma tuttavia non vuoi
quindi federico svuota appartamento no
no l'immagine che tuttora boston
bruciano davanti al letto il messaggio
il clown è morta ha perso sei proprio
usare l'informatica a lei ciao non ti
mando un vocale solo perché sono senza
voce per l'influenza
negli anni ho avuto una quantità
esagerata di brutti regali che non mi
meritavo
ma credo che il podio sia decisamente da
dare a questi due alla bottiglia di
questa dovra cosa che adesso sarà
riempita di odio
e poi sempre sono messi una lampadina
serve la presa e basta no dico che
questo è un non sono mai stato in
calabria la calabria si dimentica quello
che vedi foto
il regalo di natale più ma che abbia mai
ricevute nella mia vita non lo smalto
lui dalla frutta sembrava con candito
tenero peluche e il police quando in
realtà perdeva perina persone che un
occhio a ciccione colosso che poi
diventerà square cio senza un occhio e
po morbida l'ha fatta di plastica dura
ti sei reso conto che questa è la tua
faccia con quel cappello ciao
allora come può vedere dalla foto è
regalato aver ricevuto regista è stato
questa specie di cui non c'è di vero
infatti un altro messaggio scusa
praticamente la cugina di mia madre ha
deciso che per natale vale variano
questo nuovo che dalla foto non si
capisce ma è alto circa mezzo metro
sotto il cappello allungato i settori
alzano il fratello ea tutta la faccia
completa sulla materia era solo quello
che credo che portava fortuna proprio di
questo grazie a dio il mio cane io dico
che se ti avrei mai sbranato distretto
presente la scusa del comparto ragazza
solo l'anno ecco adriano santucci
spaccio non si è fatto da solo un regalo
di mercato su amazon e un massaggiatore
per i piedi elettrica
io ha mantenuto questa scena di lui
seduto al suo tavolo che lavora tanto
sottotenente spremuta di calli che poi i
piedi delle delle signore avete mai
fatto caso che hanno in realtà la luce
in mezzo cioè quando loro hanno le
scarpe del buco le scritte col buco che
il buco in mezzo esce sempre l'altro si
sposti il buco essere anche seguiti sul
pallone
ciao q scusami ma sono le due di notte
quindi devo sussurrare per il tema
regali di scusami dormono tutti a casa
parlerò piano il regalo del paese molto
amico andrea in questo contesto un
bellissimo e il 38 o tipo scaturito da
metterci le cose non hanno proprio per
sé che era il mio manager costruiscono
sole quindi penso che tutte le cose di
valore che ho ricevuto da mia nonna
siano proprio di valore ecco ma se n'è
ricordato era un portagioielli si può
una scatola perché non lo facesse cose
con i tovaglioli di oli sono anche
carine
eccolo eccolo eccolo dico solo che abito
in un appartamento non a giorni 5 è il
nano da giardino senza giardino è
proprio un po comodo lo metti davanti la
porta e la chiude i ladri un regalo di è
stato questo cerchietto verde decorato
con un filo di foglie e una per a me
l'hanno regalato i miei amici
imbarazzante
ma tu non ti scordar mai di me non ha
anche chiesto di regalarmi un intimo
rosso quando avevo l'età di codici e 11
anni deve sistemare nei modelli completo
per domare marito e come vendola lo vede
veglia 12 anni peripatetica regalati che
neanche ha mai ricevuto mi è stata fatta
dalla ragazza che è dalla scorsa
tagliata la linea regalato un bel air
tra barcellona e questo viaggio era
stata fatta dalla va a trovare la sua ex
ragazza che studia riesce a cui siamo
stati ospiti per la settimana del nostro
viaggio con cui poi si è diversa e dopo
avermi lasciato e l'elica tanto in
italia ma di fatto almeno la fiancata
della macchina gli ho dato fuoco a
qualcosa l'aereo della ba un insieme di
icone di realtà questo te lo sto
mandando perché vorrei che mi aiutasse a
capire esattamente che cos'è e cosa le
hanno regalato ragazzi che cos'è secondo
voi che cos'è secondo aspetto in centro
dove potrete l'incenso
bravo comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video io ti
ringrazio matteo per aver preso parte a
questa follia è sempre un piacere
ringrazio anche now tv con la sua stick
per avermi dato la possibilità di creare
questa follia
ringrazio voi che mi avete mandato dei
messaggi ringrazio medi esiste umile
come finale mi piace adesso andiamo via
ciao